Електоральна революція триває.
"Слуга народу" накопичує політичні рекорди:
понад 40% голосів за списками партій
та більше половини мандатів мажоритарників.
Отримати цього на парламентських виборах в Україні
ще не вдавалося жодній партії.
Із такими результатами "слуги народу" можуть
створити і прецедент однопартійної більшості.
Втім, Зе-команда розглядає різні варіанти.
- Я сподіваюся, що це буде велика фракція.
Можливо, і ми зможемо створити більшість.
Але подивимося.
Ми б хотіли об’єднуватися з тими політичними силами, які:
а) є новими; б) які відповідали б тим моральним якостям
та підходам, які сповідує наша політична сила.
Від команди Порошенка вже пролунали сигнали
про необхідність пошуку спільних точок зору.
Його партія "Європейська солідарність", за даними екзитполів,
посідає третє місце. Але, швидше за все,
в коаліцію вона не увійде.
Якщо партія "Слуга народу" і захоче з кимось утворювати союз,
то правила диктуватиме саме вона.
- Враховуючи близькість ідеологічну
і навіть по особистих зв’язках є багато спільного,
"Голос" буде в коаліції. Тобто буде коаліція на двох.
"Батьківщина" теоретично може долучитися до коаліції…
Якщо візьмуть.
І, безумовно, ніхто не буде брати до уваги вимоги якісь.
Юлія Тимошенко одразу по завершенню голосування
заявила, що може бути в коаліції лише зі "Слугою народу" та "Голосом".
Більше того, Тимошенко наголосила, що її політсила
з четвертим результатом виборів на жодні посади не претендує.
А от у Вакарчука прямо заявили, що їхній лідер
може претендувати на посаду голови уряду.
- Ви правильно сказали, що Святослав Вакарчук
має докторську дисертацію з фізики.
Він закінчив курс навчання в Єлі і в Стенфорді.
У нас небагато було прем’єрів з такою освітою,
чесно вам скажу. Тому гірше точно не буде.
Прем’єром навряд чи зможе бути людина
не від правлячої партії, а от в уряді можуть бути
представники того ж "Голосу", передбачає політолог Володимир Фесенко.
У парламенті комітети мають розподілити
за принципом квот відповідно до чисельності фракцій.
Спікером, за традицією, може бути і представник партнера по коаліції.
- Але, враховуючи таку вражаючу перемогу "Слуги народу",
я не здивуюся, якщо і прем’єр, і спікер буде від цієї партії.
Тим більше, що лідер партії "Слуга народу"
Дмитро Разумков, схоже, що хоче бути головою ВР.
Але і "Голос", і "Батьківщина", і "Європейська солідарність"
отримують керівні посади в деяких комітетах.
Друга партія парламенту "Опозиційна платформа - За життя",
швидше за все, не зможе розраховувати ані на крісло віцеспікера -
на це націлений Медведчук, - ані навіть на комітети.
Відверто проросійську ідеологію
більшість нового парламенту навряд чи прийме.
ОП-ЗЖ фактично вже пішла в опозицію.
- Радикальна зміна економічного курсу країни -
цього ми чекаємо від парламенту.
І ми, знаходячись в опозиції, будемо робити
все задля того, аби добитися цього від тих, хто буде входити в коаліцію.
На цих виборах зафіксована рекордно низька явка виборців - менше 50%.
Літній сезон та низька довіра до парламенту - головні причини.
До результатів виборів українці ставляться по-різному.
- Я в шоці від того, що за ОПЗЖ є ще люди, які голосують.
Націоналісти - шкода, що не зайшли взагалі.
Я думаю, це дякуючи Тягнибоку.
- Мені Зеленського просто шкода.
Я його поважаю як людину. Але куди він потрапив?
Чи вистачать в нього сил боротися за все?
Я і за "Голос" теж.
А Тимошенко, якщо вона туди потрапила, ось нехай тепер
доводить все те, що вона говорила.
- Це, в принципі, нормальна тенденція, що
старих політиків усе менше. Але мені не подобається інша тенденція, що
до влади приходять люди абсолютно без досвіду.
94-го, 91-го року народження. Я не можу довіряти цим людям.
- Молоді люди, напевно, такі, як я, хочуть вже проявити себе
і показати, що в наших руках країна
може досягти більших висот.
- Я думаю добре буде, якщо не буде
повальної більшості однієї партії, а буде
певне врівноваження за рахунок інших сторін.
- Прийшли люди різного характеру, різних поглядів.
Як Зеленський втримає цих людей,
як вони зможуть працювати - це буде видно далі.
Першим випробуванням для нового парламенту
має стати голосування за скасування
депутатської недоторканності, як це обіцяє "Слуга народу".
А от наскільки нові люди в політиці готові до реформ,
можна буде побачити ближче до кінця осені.
Приміром, під час формування держбюджету.